[Music]
as the memory of men is frail and weak
it would be impossible to remember
everything accurately with regard to all
our great and important affairs
unless we avail ourselves of writing
to assist us in our purposes
at the time when the spaniards first
landed in this country of peru
and when they arrived at the city of
cajamarca which is about 190 leagues
from here
my father manco inca was residing in the
city
of cusco there he governed with all the
powers that had been bestowed upon him
by his father weiner kapak he first
learned of the spaniard's arrival
from certain messengers who had been
sent there from one of his brothers by
the name of atawalpa
who was older but a bastard and by some
indians from the lowlands called tayanas
who live on the coast of the south sea
fifteen or twenty leagues from kahamaka
they reported having observed that
certain people had arrived in their land
people who were very different to us in
custom and dress and that they appeared
to be
vera kochas this is the name that we
used to apply to the creator
of all things they named the people as
such because they differed much from us
in clothing and appearance
and because they rode very large animals
with silver feet
by which they meant the glittering
horseshoes another reason for calling
them so was that the indians saw them
alone
talking to white cloths as a person who
would speak to another
which is how the indians perceived the
reading of books and letters
moreover they called them viracochas
because of the stately appearance of
their persons
and because each was so different from
the other some having black beards and
others
red ones and finally because they saw
them eat out of silver dishes
and using yappas which is the word we
use for thunder
and by which they meant their guns for
they thought
that the thunder they made came from the
sky
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
here at voices of the past we give you
the raw source without commentary
and a great place to go if you want to
dive in deeper to some of these places
and time periods
is magellan tv they're huge supporters
of history content on youtube
me and my brother especially so if this
video gives you a taste of south america
our recommendation this week is brazil
from above
which will dive you right into beautiful
amazonian landscapes
a great antidote to 2021 claustrophobia
and there really isn't a better time to
try out the more than 3 000
documentaries magellan has available
and you can now take advantage of an
exclusive offer 30
off an annual membership this gives you
an entire year for less than 3.50 a
month
even if you've joined magellan before
and lapsed you can simply click on the
link in the description
to claim your discounted membership
today thanks
two of these vera coaches were brought
to my uncle attawalpa by some men from
the juncker people
at the time atawalpu was staying at
kahamarca where he received them very
well
however when he offered the customary
drink in a golden cup
to one of them the spaniard pulled it
out with his own hands
which offended my uncle very much
after that those two spaniards showed my
uncle a letter or a book
explaining to him that this was the book
of god and of the king
my uncle still offended by the wasting
of the chica which is how we call our
drink
took the letter or whatever it was and
threw it down
saying what is this supposed to be that
you gave me here
be gone there upon the spaniards
returned to their companions
and related to them what they had seen
and what had happened during their
dealings with my uncle
ato helper
many days later my uncollateral walker
was engaged in war and altercations with
one of his brothers
waskar inca over the question of who was
the rightful king of this land
in any case while these two brothers
sons of different mothers
were caught up in these said
altercations it was reported that 40 or
50 spaniards had arrived at cajamarca
the town mentioned above on their
well-equipped horses
my uncle attawalpa learned of this while
he was celebrating a certain festival
and immediately set out with his
entourage however he brought no weapons
for battle or harnesses for defense
only thomes which is how we call our
knives
and lassos for the purpose of hunting
this new kind of llama
which is how we called our livestock and
also their horses
since we had never seen any before not
concerned about the few people who would
come or interested in who they were
they brought only the tomes and knives
for skinning and quartering the animals
when my uncle was approaching cajamarco
with all of his people
the spaniards met them at the springs of
konak one and a half leagues from
kajamarka
having arrived there he asked them why
they had come and they answered that
they had come on orders of the viracocha
in order to tell him
how to get to know him after having
heard what they had to say my uncle
attended to them and calmly offered one
of them a drink in the manner i've
already described above
in order to see if these people too
would waste the drink
and indeed it happened just like before
having seen how little they minded his
things my uncle said
if you disrespect me i will also
disrespect you
he got up angrily and raised a cry as
though he wanted to kill the spaniards
however the spaniards were on the
lookout and took possession of the four
gates of the plaza where they were
which was enclosed on all its sides the
indians were thus penned up like sheep
and this enclosed plaza
unable to move because there were so
many of them
after they had taken everything from him
they apprehended him and because the
indians utter loud cries they started
killing them with the horses
the swords or guns like one kills sheep
without anyone being able to resist them
of more than ten thousand not even 200
escaped
when all were dead they took my uncle to
a jail where they kept him
all night stark naked and his neck in
shackles
the next day in the morning they gave
him his clothes and asked
are you the king of this country he
answered that he was
and they said there is none other beside
you for we know that there is another
one called
manco inca where is he my uncle answered
in cusco they asked and where is that
cusco
[Music]
meanwhile while the spaniards were still
deliberating whether or not to send the
messenger
the talana people on the coast found out
about the whole thing and because they
respected my father a great deal and
acknowledged him as their king
decided to bring the news themselves to
my father without informing the
spaniards
thus they left for cusco and upon their
arrival addressed my father with these
words
sappainka which means you our soul
lord we have come to tell you that a new
sort of people
have arrived in your land a race that
has never been heard of or seen before
by our nations and that without doubt
appears to be that of the viracochas
they have arrived in kajamarka where
your brother is he has told them in no
uncertain terms that he is the lord and
king of this country
this has caused us as your vassal's
great grief
when my father heard this he was beside
himself and said how dare these people
intrude into my country without my
authorization and permission
who are these people and what are their
ways the messengers answered
lord these people cannot but be
viracochas
for they claim to have come by the wind
they are bearded people
very beautiful and white they eat out of
silver plates
even their sheep who carry them a large
and wear silver shoes
finally there are people whose only
visible parts are their hands and their
face
the clothes that they wear are even
better than yours for they contain
gold and silver my father who was the
type of man who wanted to know things
for certain
turned to threatening the messengers
saying you better be sure that you
haven't lied to me in these things that
you report
for you know very well how my ancestors
and myself deal
with liars if you are so eager to
testify to the arrival of these people
why don't you go and bring one of them
to me so i can see them
and thereby be persuaded
[Music]
once they had arrived in cusco they were
introduced to my father who received
them very respectfully and supplied them
with shelter and everything they needed
the next day he invited them to his
residence and hosted a great celebration
with many people and much display of
gold and silver dishes
among them innumerable pitchers cups
bowls and pots
from the same material when the
spaniards caught a glimpse of so much
gold and silver
they told him to let them have some of
it so that they could show it to the
marquis and his companions
in order to demonstrate to them the
greatness of his power
my father agreed and gave them many
pictures golden cups and other regalia
and precious pieces for themselves
and some for their companions when the
two spaniards arrived at the place where
the marquis don francisco pizarro was
staying with the messengers and the news
that my father had sent
the marquis whom we used to call macho
capito
was assured that my father was the true
king of the entire land
the one who was respected feared and
recognized as such by all
while at a whalpa his older brother
ruled the land as a tyrant
demarquis was extremely delighted either
because he had good news from my father
of how high a person he was
or because of the exquisitely beautiful
and generous gift that my father had
sent
but he was upset by the news that my
father's brother vexed and molested him
so much
without any reason and that he had
usurped his kingdom in defiance of all
laws
however as it turned out later atawalpa
did not escape the punishment
that he deserved
when my uncle attawalpa saw that my
father had sent messengers and so much
gold and silver to the spaniards
he was upset not only was it not lost on
him how quickly my father
had aligned himself with them and they
recognized him as the legitimate king
and lord
but also he thought that this alliance
would be his doom
as he was harboring the suspicion and
fear of being cornered he decided to
summon all of his people and captains
who were with him
in order to apprise them of the sad
condition in which he found himself
these people who have entered our lands
hold notions contrary to our own
and have aligned themselves with my
brother manco inca and seem to live in
great harmony with him
if you are in agreement we will dash
their heads in
and kill them for i believe that
although we have but a few brave men
we can again rule this land the way we
used to
the men and captains who had heard the
reasoning of my uncle agreed and cried
in unison
who supply inca which means you have
spoken truly
lord it's time to kill these spaniards
for what can they do against us
all of them together wouldn't even make
a lunch for us
however soon after they determined the
day and hour on which they wanted to
carry out their plot
the marquis i don't know how found out
about it
thus the marquis had them for lunch
before they could have him
because he now knew about the conspiracy
against the spaniards
he positioned his spies everywhere and
ordered highest alert
without delay he had my uncle attawalpa
brought out of prison
into the open and without any resistance
garrotted him on a pole in the middle of
the square
and as soon as this was done he set out
to depart
in order to see my father
but no matter how quickly he acted the
indians still came down upon him
like a rainstorm for an indian by the
name of chalkochima
atawalpa's general and another by the
name of kisgis
his companion both of whom were very
brave and powerful
had gathered a great multitude of people
to avenge the death of their lord
when my father had news about the
distress in which they found themselves
he decided to raise men who would rush
to their aid
thus he departed from cusco with more
than one hundred thousand people
and came to meet the marquis who had
already captured chalcochima
the marcus was very happy to see my
father who had traveled with his golden
and crystal litters
and his royal crown the marquis turned
over chalkochima to my father
with the following words look here manko
inca
here i brought you your arch enemy in
chains decide for yourself what you want
to do with him
when my father saw him he ordered that
he be burnt
immediately before everyone's eyes
so that this news would reach his ally
kiskis and thus
be a punishment for the former and an
example for the latter
after the punishment against so bad an
indian as he was had been executed
they went together to cusco
my father was later satisfied to learn
of the death of the traitor kiskis
and called upon all his people to pay a
tribute for the spaniard's sustenance
while the tribute was being collected my
father presented them with a great
amount of treasure
that had been given to him by his
ancestors the governor and his men
received them most happily and
gratefully
when the spaniards saw themselves so
enriched they wanted to return to their
home country
but my father who considered them to be
newcomers to his country
did not want to let them go but told
them that he still wanted the pleasure
of their company
and wanted to keep them in the country a
little while longer so that they could
inform their own country adequately
about his thus they spent many days in
cusco in my father's company
and enjoyed themselves thoroughly but
greed
so powerful in all men overcame them so
completely
that they were seduced by the devil
always a friend of all evil and enemy of
virtue to conspire and plot in secrecy
how and by what means they would torment
my father and extort a greater amount of
silver and gold than what they had
already extorted from him
when my unsuspecting father a few days
after this plot had been forged
was serenely staying in his house more
than a hundred spaniards came with
treacherous intentions
under the pretext of paying him a visit
we have found out to manko inca that you
are planning to rise up against us just
like your brother attawalpa in order to
destroy us
be informed however that the governor
has ordered us to arrest you
and put you in chains so that you are
unable to harm us
while my father saw them so determined
he was very upset and exclaimed
what have i done to you that you should
treat me in this manner and chain me
like a dog
is this how you reciprocate the favors i
have done you by guiding you through my
land and making you many loving presence
of things that i owned here
you were doing me very wrong
have i not sent you a large amount of
gold and silver to kakamaka
and have you not taken from my brother
attawalpa that which rightfully had been
passed down to me by my ancestors
have i not given you everything in this
city that you desired
the sum of which equals a huge amount
more than six million
the spaniards as though they were
blinded by their evil greed
replied whatever sapphire inca
don't waste your breath making excuses
for we have proof
that you are intending to start an
uprising in the entire land
listen men bring some shackles
[Music]
[Music]
you